[Music]
[Music]
dancing fool
hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv and movie channel i am here
this evening with my resident american
i'm pointing the wrong way
i'm here as an american
jesus lord i'm gonna take that man
oh sorry i didn't mean to blame
oh now i can't hear you
oh
oh well
all right and that was it please you
know thanks for joining us for the live
stream
[Music]
oh that is bad let's just drop you out
there for a second
and we'll pop you back in and see if
that's any better because you sounded
like
is this any better
much better thank you very
much good guys
how are you stormy i am doing quite well
sir how are you
not bad not bad mate not bad um so how
oh one second i'll be back
are you gonna pee again
are you gonna lock the door behind you
i might have left the air conditioning
up so we don't need people listening to
that so anyway guys welcome to our live
show it's starting off professional as
always and we're going to be doing this
every couple of weeks just chatting with
you guys you can get into the comments
tell us what you
want to talk about and we'll talk about
what we want to talk about even in
monkey and
yoda
we're going to
yeah
so get in the comments tell us what you
want to talk about but
i'm going to start today
i'm going to store me and tell you about
that i've actually got around to
watching boba fett
it took me a little while to watch boba
fett it took me a little while to get
into boba fett deal god that show
started slow
i did it's like mandalorian i got
through the first half a season and then
i sort of like i'm gonna give up
and then i watch one more episode and i
was like this is the best show ever oh
my god this is wonderful it's so good
i i feel like that with boba fett as
soon as boba fett stopped being in it
it actually got really good
um
you know i'm not lying though am i the
best i think that's some of the best two
star wars
series
um episodes
i've ever seen
and he wasn't in it at all except for
the end of the last six but he didn't
actually say anything in the lenses he
actually had cameo it was a cameo yeah
yeah he just stood in the background
instead of looking smoke and then um
but i tell you what me
you were telling me that one of your
friends though absolutely hated the show
and i forgot before i mean he he uh had
this romanization of boafet being a
total badass
not the ps ptsd survivor of the
digestive tract of sarlacc you know
and uh
for me i really love the show but for
different reasons that most people don't
grok in in the the
there's this whole culture of the tuscan
raiders that we just haven't seen before
you know and the the tribal aspects and
the warrior aspects and how they
this this whole june sea used to be
their land
when there was water
on tatooine
and i mean it was just really really in
depth i i just love the [ __ ] out of that
you know and
beaufort you know goes from prisoner
to respected elder and he learns i think
along the way that
you know taking vader's money just ain't
worth it
because he gets thrown in the sarlacc
pit
and i think he looks at the scene but
he's climbing out to that
i did i thought that was great but you
can see the stormtroopers sort of slowly
digesting as you slip down right right
right yeah just ooh that was i did like
that yeah and for the last episode one
with um timothy olyphanty i'm a big
timothy elephant oh dude right right
um you know i i want to see him from
that show that he was in years ago oh
god i knew his name really
uh though
he was uh he did like uh what was it
he was a cop show where he wear a cowboy
hat oh
right right right yes justified he was
brilliant to that i loved that show and
he was the bad guy you know die hard for
as well and he was quite good
for yeah and uh deadwood
first time i ever saw him was hbo's
deadwood
oh you know i never saw edward i
the writing was almost
took swearing to a shakespeare-esque
kind of level i mean the swearing in
deadwood was amazing i learned a thing
and then the british actors went over
and showed you how to do it exactly
it wasn't sure i'd say i only ever saw
maybe one or two episodes in that i
never really got into it put in but you
know
we we take we we're pretty good at
swearing we invented it after all so oh
yeah you did and then we copied we
invented everything else i think was
actually scottish that invented swearing
they're good at it
and but now i really enjoyed it but in
iceland i was thinking about was
watching like the star wars lineup over
the next 12 months and i think in christ
disney squeezing every last blood out of
that stone of star wars um but then i
was actually watching um
booker bob affair
and i suddenly realized it's not it's
not like a different series it's what we
should be calling this this should be
like the favro saga
sort of thing right yeah
no it's like it's it's just chapters
within a story going on going you know
like different aspects and you know
switching fast forwards and i'm just
wondering if a lot of the other tv shows
are going to carry on i mean um
starbucks character um
i forgot her name
is going to be her own series apparently
and i'm like well that's just going to
be linked to the mandalorian again and
um it just goes on and on um but
but i mean i think they've got like six
different shows coming this year or
and early next year um
[Music]
yeah the valve universe
well that's what i'm kind of thinking i
mean it's if you look at how you know
disney has handled the mcu
you know you know where there's the main
thread and then there's all these side
threads you know
and i it's kind of like that i mean you
know it's there's a little i mean boba
fett was in mandalorian and it's just
there's this
interest
basically when and and i guess this is a
we've got spoilers alerts let's just say
right now there's going to be spoilers
but when um grogu
relives his adventures with order 66
right
you think oh
[ __ ]
you know and it's just
and then there's the slight mentions you
know from the bad batch
you know of the padawan they rescued
don't say who it was
you know it is all entangled yeah
but you're absolutely right it's just
one solid story with
titles favreau was a big part of why the
mcu went the way it did he was
very much involved in the iron man
series very much i think so i mean
they've also took his expertise and just
gone right here's the star wars story go
do what you want with it sort of thing
it obviously is and um
like i said it takes a little bit of
time to get through the initial
um slow pace of the series but once you
do when you start to appreciate
um you know the the the style of it um i
love i just like the end sequence so
they have you know like the um the drawn
pictures and even just like little bits
like that
there's such a it's such a nuanced show
as well and there's so much to it i just
i i've really actually fallen in love
with it a little bit and the blues
i fell in love with as soon as bubba
fett [ __ ] off there that was great but
you know the you you talking about those
end drawings what was the the the he did
a lot of um
character drawings for lucas back in the
day what was that guys that this
artist's name that did all those
sketches the visualization
somebody in the uh side chat needs to
get onto that pretty quick yeah yeah
i remember he uh there was a story that
lucas told one time
uh or or um
about um originally casting c-3po he had
the uh like uh 3po on you know
kind of on the crest of it of a tatooine
dune
he just was you know in his standard
stance and um
that was kind of the inspiration for the
actress that he couldn't figure out how
to do so threepio so he saw that that
sketch and he's like this is it
[Music]
it reminded me of him and those those
drawings are really emotive i think
i think it's great how much concept art
is used in in movies and tv shows and
things like that as well i still did a
video recently about stargate saying
about how they're preparing all the
concept art for hopefully the new series
that's coming and that's one of the
things they do at the moment they're
sort of mgm can't really do anything
with stargate at the moment they're
waiting for it to sort of get everything
to get sort of agreed
and but one of the things they are doing
is doing concept art and i was sort of i
was so pumped by that and a couple of
people come back and went so
now you don't understand this is bit the
describe decides the whole look of the
show when they do this concept art it is
so important for the for you know for
the rest of the show sort of thing um
this is when the decisions get made
you know so yeah that's i think the
concept artist is sort of one of those
um
people in tv shows uh yeah and
you know don't get us enough credit
really ralph mcqueary is the guy i'm
thinking of
oh well done
no idea that is so you've got one on me
there
just having a nice glass of wine this
evening by the way oh yeah it's the last
of the christmas wine so
cook see
talking about whatever ones are the cook
kind of coca-cola ones advice there
hello
so else you've been watching stormy in
this in these last couple of
um
discovery of witches that's going very
well i think i think i'm up to episode
three of the last series um yeah
i finally finished off star trek prodigy
we haven't got it in the uk you haven't
watched any
oh my god
it's um
it's really good i mean you know you
think it's
you know it's like bad batch was going
to be you know for the younger audiences
and bad bats just turned out to be
badass
and throwed it up and prodigy is just
really good star trek you know lots of
mystery and and uh hologram gene way
just excellent
i keep watching the um i watch
at one of the star trek channels anyway
and they do the ups and downs of each
episode and i watch everyone so i kind
of know what's happened through the
series um there's a big um conspiracy
theory at the moment they think that the
proto-star might be actually what causes
the burn in discovery
um
but um so i'm like oh that's interesting
um
so i keep watching it and i'm just like
i really want to see this show so i'm
gonna have to get a vpn and
trick my
um my netflix into think i'm i'm in i'm
i'm your neighbor
and then you must be able to watch it
but um
it's on netflix i don't know what it's
on to be honest
i have to watch it on paramount plus
here in the us it's it's done nothing
over here
you just went very loud for a second by
the way
i don't know
did i get too close to the i don't know
how am i now a little bit loud so well
okay
i love hearing your salty tones so don't
worry
well thank you very much
um but yeah i mean it's one of those
shows and i love the style of it and
stuff and i'm like that's proper star
trek
but then i see the advert or the little
sneak peek of the orville that's just
come on and i did i did add it to the
channel i linked it to the facebook
group but new horizons is that right
that looks really good
i mean that is proper star trek i feel
really really awkward
loving that so much
well we should because it was like a
joke wasn't it for so long and i i
really think he's dialed the humor back
a lot yeah you still get the odd you
know um american dad joke or whatever
but he's dialed it back loads
considering collecting the first series
and it's become a far more serious
sci-fi show as it's gone on um and i
love that but oh yeah yeah
i still have the odd little joke here
and there a little stoner joke and what
have you but um
but this next series just looks
it looks really good
i was like that's right so um kurtzman
needs to look at what he's doing with
star trek
at the moment um and then he needs to
look at the oval and go oh
that's star trek oh i got so confused
because i mean we're looking at
strange new worlds
i'm not excited about that show at all
um
they're talking about doing the section
31 series which would be
michelle yo hello
um love her uh i i i really want to see
um oh god her character's name has been
out my head now georgia
i want to see her another show she's
fantastic um and then there are now
backgrounds starfleet academy which i
don't want to see at all
yeah it's i mean it'd be fun you know as
long as it's not you know dorm
shenanigans you know
i mean i i don't want it to turn into um
oh you know ryan reynolds movie you know
it's just
i think it's going to be starfleet 90210
um i i think it's going to be a teen
drama and i don't want to watch star
trek team drama
i have enough team drama having 12 year
old lads in my house
i don't i don't need to see that
um and speaking of the actresses you
know it's i can't believe like mean
when when
15 years old
sorry
what happened to me i mean
man
i'm half her age nearly and she looks
like i did i've never looked like that
it's like yeah
she just looks like old just old enough
to drink
i remember in i mean years ago now she
was in
um two and a half men and she was dating
charlie sheen's character right but the
whole thing about her was that she was a
hot woman in her mid-40s
how long ago did that show get cancelled
that the charlie sheen before winning
bit happened you know she is insanely
gorgeous i mean she's done whole shields
of agents of shield since then
you know but she's 59 years old i saw
her story going fans are shocked and
understand how old she actually is and
i'm like she's gotta be in the 50s and i
looked up and even i was sort of going
crashed i knew she was old i didn't know
she was 59. and she also stargate
universe
yes she was she was a politician target
where it is
a very big part in that though she's
very background in that yeah yeah yeah
she wasn't a big she didn't have a big
part in that but um yeah i forgot she
was in that to be fair but yeah she was
um
she's done some great stuff over the
years um but i think this is her best
character i love her in this
yeah um
is a really good character yeah the way
she bounces off boba fett you see how we
like to circle background to bother fat
now it's like we did it right right
right right right so
and we were talking about olefont
earlier but the scene with him and um
cab bane
that was good
is this he brought the you know that
matt dillon kind of
american west
vibe to it i mean i don't know if you've
watched a lot of gun smoke uh my game
pants did it means i did
and um
i don't know how much you guys have been
infused with the mythology of the
american west
but man
yeah yeah yeah i mean i mean i you know
i have literal cowboys living next you
know near me and um
he really did a good job of that whole
you know frontier my town you know kind
of
that and olefin's just a [ __ ] good
actor i mean he he just i love
his performances he sold the fear though
didn't he he when he saw ben come in and
he was still like straight away like
everybody get inside yeah this isn't
right
don't argue like that idiot
um sheriff at the um the deputies
they're going i i'm going to kill this
guy you know and tim costa's like you
endorse
something
um
no i thought it was great um i saw her
there was a meme today on him and it's
um
[Music]
ah sheriff and then it's a picture of
being next to him going because um i i
shot the sheriff because then he's back
to thinking but he didn't shoot the
deputy and then it's back to bain and
just like
because he didn't shoot the deputy did
you
i did
yeah but i mean the way they did that
again it was proper spaghetti western it
was old-school 60s good bad in the ugly
sort of thing
exactly which is another meme that's
come out the good the bad and the
ugliness yeah yeah yes
boba fett
yeah right right right in the ugly
but yeah no i i love the way they did
that because it was
again it's it's that thing the different
genres and there's always been like a
western sort of vibe in star wars there
always has been that spirit western type
of feel yeah and that just like it
boiled it down for me
the other thing i liked in those two
episodes though is um the mandalorian's
new ship
right that was great that star fighter i
just i'd love how they took that and
they could have um
you know like
rebuilt it and made it look the same but
they didn't they sort of modified it
they took all the yellow off
and they just made it into a cool ass
looking ship
and um
you know i love that
and i love the crowd the of the stadium
so the x-wings as they're like chasing
it sort of thing and he goes
that's like
one of the celebrities
kicking in
i just i just i thought that was great
that's honestly it's the it's the
probably my favorite two
of those sort of shows i mean i'm going
to throw in
anything on disney plus in the last 12
months 18 months i mean and i loved loki
i thought loki was great
loki's another one of those shows just
like
three four episodes in like what the
hell is this
what it's just and then it's just like
oh oh my god oh my god let me tell you
the meme from you know
the ultimate there is a scarlet witch
wasn't it that was me
that show was like my i sat my don't
voice watch this because right here we
go this is going to be really important
for um for the next phase of marvel we
have to watch this because we have to
understand it you know like come on sit
down and watch it and for the first
three episodes my sons were looking at
me like
what the f is this what what is going on
um and even on there after the third
episode going they really need to do
something now i mean okay this is all
very clever
well done sort of thing on the uh all
the set pieces or whatever but you need
to crack on because this is boring and
um and then they did
they did yeah the last three or four
episodes were great but
i think this this book book of bob
affair
the last couple of episodes have been
yeah they've been some of the best
that sort of show i've ever seen i've
loved them
who's the director for the uh the ring
world episode was that
bryce howard
i don't know because there's been a
different director each episode hasn't
it so because john pepper has obviously
done a couple
um and he i think he writes them all i
think whoever writes them all he writes
or co-writes all of them yeah yeah but
the director the whoever director the
sixth one also
co-wrote it
i noticed
um but i didn't catch his name but um
but yeah so
it's also a collaborative effort a
little bit i love that that that was in
uh on a ring world you know
you know i've always liked that as a
concept everyone said oh they copied it
off halo
well there was this book from 1970
that was called ring world by larry
niven that
you know skunk them all and if you
haven't read the ring world or the
following books i suggest that you do
because it's very very good you can't
really say you're a sci-fi fan i'm not
i've read him to be honest i'm just
saying
amazon are supposedly
in early production of making a
ringworld series so let's see if they
ever actually get around to that but
they've been supposedly
for about three years
apparently they've owned the rights to
it and been steadily building up to
doing it and they think that was one of
the reasons why it appeared in that was
um because
that's the
the projects on the go and they wanted
to sort of have a little nod to it sort
of thing but um
that's but that's another one that
actually favors supposed to be involved
in but favre is supposed to be involved
in everything now he's very popular at
disney um very busy man um because
supposedly there's going to be a firefly
reboot
which we keep getting having banded
around like what's going to happen it's
going to happen but apparently and
inside on another youtube channel some
insider said that um five layers
definitely happened it's confirmed and
and favreau is going to and his team are
going to be making it and i'm like have
you seen his schedule for the next 12
months two years
when is he making firefly i was i was
completely on board with this until you
said that
i mean you know if he gets any busier he
will be making my breakfast i'm just you
know what else is there for him left to
do on earth yeah i think that should be
he should leave some television and
films to other people it's a bit like
morgan freeman it's just like don't be
in everything
it's just like you know leave some films
samuel jackson and morgan freeman
they're in everything
did you have you seen the new um halo
trailer yeah
it was really really good have you known
the people going a load of people are
cracked on going woke it's gonna be woke
and i'm like watch the trailer what's
woke about that i know we've had
discussions about woke before and maybe
we we you know
we scratch your head about it but
it's going to be about a 50 pound asian
girl i guess well she's in the trailer
oh god you mentioned that what was oh
there was
a fan film a fan series
it was based on um
a bunch of uh people playing dungeons
and dragons
then they worked at they worked at a uh
company called the game i think it was
um
let's see but it sounds awesome anyway
so they have the you know these master
sergeants walking around at this one
game show
you know and they're they're trying to
do something
and uh trying to get attention to
something or another in any way
so the master chiefs say all the
cosplayers for the master chiefs they're
going to go text everybody on what some
sort of app to get everybody to come to
this one event so they pop their gloves
off and they both have fingernail long
nails and funeral polish on
so that's kind of what we're doing i'm
sorry what was the name of that let's
see i don't know but you google it
but
i love the advert for him halo i know i
know somebody said oh it's going to be
about a woman
it's going to be about one of the master
chiefs you know one of the other ones
who are women because yes because it was
always a team there was always more than
just the master chief but i mean i don't
know what people are stressed about
because it's it's the probably from the
trailer it seems very much the master
chief is front and center
it's going to be very much about how the
master chief becomes sort of more than
just you know the um the the mindless
soldier that he was and the action and
the and the way they've set up looks
stunning
so i mean um i i i'm never a i've never
been a big gamer i never have been i've
got too much going on i'm too much in my
life to you know play games particularly
but i always played cod if i was going
to play
you know a shoot em up um i never really
played halo
right but i've played it with my kids a
couple of times and you know so i kind
of know a bit about it
um but even i'm looking at her going
well they they look to me like they've
done
a really um thoughtful but actually like
fans of
fans of the game sort of rendition of
the show because i mean
the master chief looks the same the
ships kind of look the same cortana
looks the same um it's it's almost like
an extension of the games which i think
is great
right
so okay so i did the googling it is uh
with felicia day
and our wonderful will wheaton and it's
called the guild
i'm going to have to google that later
because i love everything
love will wheaton hate wesley
but love will eat him um i punch was the
crusher in the face but then i'd go and
buy will wheaton a drink and have a chat
with him because he's
the legend
back in the late 80s i saw
this fan film at this little tiny
convention in north carolina
and you know it was a next-gen kind of
fan film
and uh picard goes remember to bring
weasley we can drop him in a snake pit
and the entire auditorium roared with
cheers
drop weasley in a snake pit
look yeah i i remember years ago i went
to um a star trek uh star trekathon it
was all the star trek movies back to
back
and three o'clock in the morning oh god
it was when um first contact came out so
like eight o'clock in the morning first
contact was the big that was the
premiere sort of thing right um but they
started showing the movies like eight
and nine o'clock the night before and i
remember um
the fifth one
um the
oh god when they find god i forgot i
hate that movie um
the final frontier and that was on about
four o'clock in the morning and i slept
through the whole thing
between the films though they have
little quizzes and one of the questions
was who's the most hated character of
star trek in the whole place like
where's lee
all the unison sort of thing all of a
sudden
well i i don't think the right words did
hint did him any favors i really don't
you know i mean it was just he was
supposed to be a little twit that wasn't
he kind of thing that was
you know yeah you know the you know my
favorite line i remember it you know i
think it was when he um
let loose the nanites i think it was
oh i think i know you know
he says like some you know he's talking
about you know his lab or whatever they
got into the computer in the end and it
you know and someone asked him what his
grades are i said and he just bemoans it
i always get an a
all right
[Music]
i think like i said though i think he
was supposed to be kind of hated whether
they played up on it though didn't they
think you've seen one of those um links
of all the times picard says shut up
wesley
over and over and over again did they
get off the bridge
little [ __ ] but yeah you know
when he basically went off to become a
god in that episode um with the traveler
everyone's just laughing god he's left
why do you have to leave in such a
weasly way
and you know they basically called him a
weasel in his name
you know what would be a good series for
uh
for him to come back as a role you know
as weasley
is just this guy that's the the
character has just traveled so much
that he's somehow become a cue
his fingers and doing evil crap to
people
and but then would he have radiation in
the end or is he like was he just gonna
cause terror
he'd have to be like chained but in the
end surely they'd have to like catch him
or you know all the other q would have
to turn up and sort of
stop him or something wouldn't they or
is he just gonna go on a rampage
how would that wrap up um
i never thought it through that much but
it's a card and turn up and just punch
him in the face
shut up wesley
and that would be the end of the show
mom shows up i'm sorry
his mom would show up have sex with a
ghost
and then
tell him to behave and he'd go
that's probably what because that's the
only thing i remember from beverly
christian
that's right
you don't want to rub
right saucy you're right she did that so
um
more than once
um and then told down the tutorial about
but um but now that'd be i
i don't know if i'd want to see wesley
in a in a show again but i do wonder
whether he might reappear for picard it
doesn't look like he's gunning and but
everyone else is turned up so could
wesley turn up in picard
i don't know i mean i'd really like to
see i mean it was just you know
his origin story on next generation was
is almost like set up to make him the
ultimate villain
is um uh
there's a superhero movie a few years
ago actually about a kid that basically
got super powers and he did what all of
us would do he became a complete dick
you know it's like all of a sudden he
can fly and he's stronger than everybody
else he's more powerful than everybody
else he sort of like goes well
you should all do as you told them
because like i'm the ultimate being he
doesn't do what superman did and go well
i'm better than all of you so i will try
to be a shining light he just sort of
went you go bow
and that's what we would all do we've
got superpowers maybe wesley would be
the same he'd come back to star trek is
a complete dick and you know but with
you know
freaky powers but the traveler is pretty
close to a queue from a power from a you
know i think so
from his abilities a transferring matter
into energy and whatever so
maybe maybe
i'd love to see that then we're going to
have at least one more series of picard
um i think we're pretty confident he's
not going to be in picard series two
but um
i've actually just done a video so i
won't talk about this too much because
i've just edited it so it'll ruin it
but um about basically what i think is
gonna happen with card series too but i
know me and you had a chat about it
earlier in the week about what whoopi
goldberg
came out and said
um and got herself in trouble
um
i think how would that maybe affect the
card series too i don't think it will at
all
you know i don't think anyone you know
it's just like is there any such thing
as bad press you know um
exactly i really think she really
stepped in it i mean you know talk about
you know she really needs a a publicist
to do all of her off you know off
off-hand speaking off-hand lines you
know it's just
yeah i mean if she said you know you
know uh it was all you know the uh the
way the holocaust was all about hate
no one is that a thing
yeah
i kind of know i think i know where
she's coming from being um i'm gonna
said about being a black person which
makes me sound like i i couldn't
completely understand what would it be
like to be a black man which i can't
obviously um i've got a friend who's um
he's a solicitor um and
he's always late everywhere we go he
always turns up late and it's because
anyone's like where you been mate and
he's just like i'm stopped by the police
again because i've never stopped by the
police in my life
um and he's he's
he's a solicitor and he drives a flash
car
and he's got his he's got his license
plate in the database somewhere and he
gets stopped every six months or so
they are very polite when they find out
it's a solicitor to be fair the police
are lovely once you they finally
but i have no idea what
what racism feels like but i i guarantee
you even as this successful
black person in america whoopi goldberg
knows exactly what it feels like so you
kind of understand where
she was coming from or what she was
trying to say
she just stepped in it she just said it
completely the wrong way um you know and
and i said there's a very different
difference between race and religion and
i said most
a lot of people that
you know are jewish don't actually
identify themselves with a judaist faith
you know and it's like
they're two very different subjects i'm
absolutely saying hitler didn't give a
crap so um
you know it's saying
so i i completely i completely
understand why people are so angry and
i'm completely certain why whoopi
goldberg hasn't been sacked or anything
like that because i don't think it's
like a cardinal sin
um but i can kind of understand what she
was trying to say i think she just said
it really badly
um
i don't know but yeah i mean
if you you know it's
you know here in this country you know
african americans is
that's
always been hate you know and just look
at whoopi goldberg's film the color
purple
you know
um
you know you could you know in the past
you know you could
in the 1900s you could just kill a black
person and get away with it
and and you know
you would not serve a night in jail
then they came you same thing with uh
gay people
you would never spend the night in jail
and so you know it's
it's you know
the holocaust i think you know was
i mean yeah it was just hate blind
unrational or irrational just hate just
just
fed it hate i would say they say
it could have just as easily happened in
the uk the holocaust as well i mean the
jewish
people were hated here as well they were
blamed for everything that went wrong
in society you know they were you know
they weren't um we always sort of like
oh my god this is so disgusting but
we're kind of like glossing over our own
history a little bit
um and obviously the the jewish
people race is is still mistrusted in
some quarters today even in america and
uk and you know they're all the they're
all the bankers they're all the bankers
what's going on something um there's
loads of conspiracy theories and things
about the jewish i mean
even here in america you know there was
this thing called the american bund
which i had relatives that were a part
of
i had relatives that um
loved the position of the nazis
yeah they thought hitler had the right
idea and that's here in america you know
years decades after the end of world war
ii yeah and no it's uh you know
hate it's just
anywhere
people
when things are bad people want somebody
to
blame
you know right it's something to blame
it's their fault it's that person's
wrong but anyway we're a sci-fi channel
right so so the so the real question is
is picard and dining gonna bone this
time
obviously
i mean i think you can you can tell from
the um yeah i actually think i watched a
couple of videos this is so stepping on
the video i've just finished editing but
um i did a video
about um
i watched a video sorry about it they
said q gaining explained revealed why q
is um scared of gaining revealed reveal
oh but then it goes on about how gaiden
was in the nexus and she was she because
she was ripped out the next success
that's where she got her powers from
um and apparently this comes from a
roland d moore statement that basically
said that's what they were going to go
with
they also say rome rome
ronald d more not roland
oh man i got so much [ __ ] for saying
that i did i've recorded two videos i
always record my videos in blocks of two
or three
i did a video about roland emmerich
i think
i did a video with ronald d moore
and i made a slight error
the amount of crap i got for that couple
of comments
but anyway i tried to pretend it was
just my accent but i didn't get away
with it um but anyway so ronald d moore
said that actually that was the plan but
when queue sees gaining for the first
time in cue who the episode who he says
he calls her an imp and then basically
says they're there
the last time he saw it was 200 years
ago well that would have been 100 years
at least before the nexus incident
so if she gained her powers then she
must have had something at least before
that
um but then that did lead me on to other
thinking but i'm definitely not saying
that because i've had a genius idea
about why the queue and kind and hates
the queue so much
um
but anyway i actually think in that
there were talks about how in picard
series 2 we're definitely going to have
it explained to us now we're going to
understand the the relationship between
queue and guyana and picard and i'm just
there going no we won't
but we they won't explain anything
um their their gaining will be in it
barely more than she's in the advert is
my i'm such a cynic and she will be
available this is an advert she'll just
be all mysterious again and they'll be
like oh it's in our relationship deep
and meaningful and i just want somebody
in the background to walk past and go
why
and and they go oh well because it is no
no explain this
how do you know when did you first meet
but that won't happen
we will we won't have anything and
she'll sort of go oh go do some a timey
wimey thing and fix it
and then they're just the rest of the
series is basically going to be the
voyage home that's how i think picard
series 2 is going to go i may as well
delete the video i've just finished
editing this
because that's basically my next video
in a nutshell
and looking up
goldberg's
uh imdb i didn't know they're going to
do another sister act that's interesting
yes distract three
i'm gonna go see you live doing the
sister act uh later in the year
which i'm looking forward to but yes
it's track three there's a legally
blonde three coming as well i know
you're more excited about that i'll be
honest
um that's one of the only projects that
didn't get cancelled when the mgmc went
through
they're like oh now we really have to
make this movie
do you greasy with a spoon yeah
um
but yeah i i don't think i i think this
is all going to help
picard series too it needs to be
it i mean no one will remember but times
card
season two premieres i mean it's like
you know there'll be something else
that'll capture
maybe some other [ __ ]
do you actually think then that um
because series 2 has got a chance of
actually being any good this time
well you know it's like every time that
the franchise goes back
in time
those are really good episodes you know
for one amok time
you know which was really early on in
the star trek mythology
when uh
star trek voyager
no excuse me when a ds9 goes back to san
francisco for the bell for the uh
the bail rights i think it was called
that was really good so
uh when star trek voyager goes back in
time to meet
space aliens that assume the identity of
nazis working with the nazis and as more
or less the nazis took over san
francisco that was a good episode
because it wasn't that was it i kind of
like only you know
i know actually no i'm mixing up now
enterprise
went back in time and there were space
aliens pretend to be nazis
it was the
doomsday double episode
halfway end of series three start series
four
oh right right oh yeah oh yeah i kind of
forgot about it the bad guy in that to
be fair was wicked he had a really good
the main sort of nazi right
um
temporal cold war was that the whole
that's part of the temple that was how
the temple call ended um i just think
that the writers were there going
watching the discovery channel going
people really like nazis
um and they're quite like aliens
um if we could stick sharks into this
episode somehow we'd be on a winner
you know but maybe that's why the bad
guys looked the way they did they were
trying to make them look a bit like
sharks maybe right but um you know just
like aliens and nazis come on uh but
actually i i it was it was actually a
pretty good double episode on the whole
um it's just
alien nazis
come on
bit silly
um but no fair enough um i i worry when
star trek go back in time
because i just think that's an
opportunity to go
let's step i can and let's step okay i'm
not a purist when it comes to canon
stuff gets changed all the time and
things happen
but don't peel over it
modern star trek just sort of like
thinks of canon as something
it's just a slight irritation to their
storytelling plans
and um so a bit worried about it but at
the end of the day the voyage home is
probably the best star trek of the
original movies
other than undiscovered country which is
my favorite book for different reasons
but the voyage home is a it's a classic
star trek and if you're gonna sort of
copy a movie or be inspired by one of
them
at least make it one of the good ones
so
so you know i have
high hopes
you know since this you know
historically time travel really works
well in the star trek universe
fingers crossed
the one the s9 where they went back in
the triple tribbles episode that's one
of the greatest that was that was also a
good one yeah yeah yeah that's a
fantastic start and when they bring up
the uh the klingons and they're looking
at wharf and they're looking at the
klingons they're looking at wharf and
then
we don't talk about it
sorry that's one of the things i keep
talking about they're going to explain
in discovery isn't it actually that
they're going to change the game they're
going to do another little joke about it
and i'm like
i don't watch any discovery this season
pushing none of it
we've got it on um a network over here
you know they pulled it off netflix uh
sorry yeah netflix really late in the
day yeah in the uk
and europe and the whole world they put
it on some channel called peacock
but even though it's a streaming channel
so it's on um it's on amazon
so you can watch it but it's all live so
it's like a tv show like a tv channel
like an old school tv channel
but
it's streamed
and but the thing is i can't record off
it
so i either have to watch it when it's
on
which is my snooker night or i don't
watch it so i haven't watched it
yeah peacock is owned by nbc here in
america which is owned by general
electric i think it is
and the um
the reason for the name is the nbc
peacock the old school logo course
little colored feathers you know that's
where they got this so it's essentially
for us in america
it's streamed nbc content
yeah they've really tried to push it
over here at the moment
one of the next big shows is going to be
strange new worlds i think might be on
there picard's going to be on amazon
again
um but i think strange new worlds might
be on there there's some other show as
well that's going to be on there the day
after it's live in america which i
forget what it was now and as soon as
those peacock was like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to actually watch it when
it's on such a nuisance
so all of our track stuff is on
paramount plus
which is different from paramount the
paramount streaming app which is just
paramount on cable
and you have to have cable to get the
paramount at but not true for the
paramount plus app
all right well we're getting that in
europe
in the summer we think
so and that'll be a bit like disney plus
so it took forever to come over here
yeah
like we're not if this isn't the 1980s
when when the dvd would come out in
america and we'd get about six months
later give it us now it's not that
difficult it's the file
and you don't really have to work with
you know with uh 4k you really don't
have to worry about pal versus ntsc or
whatever
yeah exactly i i don't even know what
that meant sir because i'm not i'm a
terrible techno geek i'm i'm not i'm not
a computer person but i know it's not
hard so right but i i don't know why
they're wasting time it's just
investment i suppose isn't it just
investing into it but at the end of the
day we'll we'll watch it um but i think
i think they might struggle without
those because we're tight
um and we in the uk
i have
amazon but only because i don't get free
postage and amazon keep emailing me
thinking i'm a company i buy all my crap
on amazon i live in a small town and we
haven't really got like a proper high
street so if i want something i
basically either have to drive an hour
to the to the big town or i have to buy
an amazon
and i'm very lazy so um amazon think i'm
a business i spend so much money on them
the post but i'm on first names his
first name basis for my postman his
name's joshua he's very nice hello
yeah and he keeps coming on a sunday as
well you pour sod
um
but um
so i've got amazon because of that i've
got netflix because it comes free with
my skype prescription prescription
subscription
um and i've got disney plus because all
the good stuff's on disney plus
i'm not more my wife won't let me buy
anything else
let's see i've got um
something called curiosity which is uh
by the guys that started the discovery
channel before the discover channel went
bad
and it's like a dollar a month it's just
so ridiculously cheap or 50 cents i mean
it's just so i just bought you know buy
like six dollars for a year or something
then i get hulu
[Music]
it came with my phone service
you know i order and again i order so
much from amazon that it's
just comes with my amazon stuff
um
i do pay for netflix
and i pay for
disney plus
and i pay for
paramount plus those are the three i pay
for
plus the curiosity stream which is
i think my wife i'm we're just going to
get paramount plus all of a sudden my
wife will be like how much is something
it's free don't look at the bank
statement it's free
pay it via paypal
or something yeah i'm gonna have to pay
for my credit card and hide the bill or
something i'm just gonna [ __ ] they sort
of do what disney did instead of like
making cheap to try and you know battle
with netflix sort of thing right netflix
is getting quite expensive i'm glad i
don't pay for any more really
well here's you know the way i look at
it is
um when i had cable
that was unless i had cables like
2017 i think it was and isn't just the
cable portion not the the the broadband
cable portion was like well over a
hundred dollars and i really didn't have
an extreme you know
subscriptions to everything i had hbo
and that was about it it was just really
expensive
and so when i'm watching tv i'm
typically watching four channels you
know local news hbo
and amc
and
it was just really so now with streaming
well the other thing i didn't like about
cables there's all these hundreds of
other channels that i never watch and
not so much just thoroughly hate
you know so like i'm subsidizing all
these tv preachers that's begging me for
money i just loathe that
i don't want it can't get rid of it but
i'm happily paying for it the streaming
services yeah that you know you have
five dollars here and there ten dollars
here and it adds up but
the difference is i'm
getting what i want
i'm not paying for what i don't want and
i've got too much to watch now which was
not the only one on that yeah
i was like thank god for netflix
i started watching all the spanish stuff
on netflix i'd watch so much netflix
early in the lock game
i was just like it's three months i'm
not allowed to leave the house
all those tv shows i've
never got around to watching ghost yeah
i remember doing watch out let's watch
it now that's one thing sure all right
oh good three six episodes let's watch
that yeah i've got yeah i just watched
netflix all day and it was just pause to
go to the toilet and make and go get a
drink something like i just sat on a
city it was brilliant it was just like
everything i've been told my whole life
i'm not allowed to do don't be lazy
don't sit in the center you're not good
no i'm saying
stay in the house
stay in the house don't move i just wish
disney plus have been a bit better then
i paid for disney plus then but it was
it was just disney
and it had nothing on it and then the
fox deal went through and all of a
sudden
i was like oh my god i can watch x-files
from the beginning this is awesome
and there's loads of films and they're
all awesome but
um
go back to picard series 2 though yeah
for a second the card series one we were
all excited about and then it turned out
in the end to be rubbish
could queue
come back in time when he reappears
realize that picard is an android and
fix that [ __ ] heap of a plot hole or of
a [ __ ] up to the story surely he could
click his fingers and make picard human
again right
sure why doesn't he do that that i'd
watch that
q is a jackass
or so
right right right just doing this
you're still an android
yes
picard is an android poop
eat or drink
or anything like that
well he you know he there's this uh in
the trailer for the next season
you know the whole earl grey gig or gag
yeah
but so i guess so oh carlos couldn't
date it
could also
could he probably he could drink and he
could eat
and he was fully functional
so um
so yeah maybe so um that is a good point
actually gainan
senses him walk in
and goes i'm going to need some earl
grey hat
sort of thing
um sorry that's my american accent
you're proud
um
uh how did she do that because he's an
android
well you know i was thinking about that
you know and when uh next generation
when they go back in time to san
francisco and they find data's head
underneath with mark twain
it was did she
she didn't seem to
she seemed to you know detect him as
like you know as a person i thought she
didn't seem to like
well he he's a bag of bolts and they
were them
she treated him like a sentient being
remember or am i just misremembering
yeah no i think i know what you mean he
sees so she treated him like a son
almost i thought she she tried to be
like a mother figure but she did to
everybody i suppose i don't ever
remember doing anything that was she
detected him but um
i don't know she wasn't really in the
one with them with law and that was you
know we didn't really see her in those
episodes
[Music]
i don't think so yeah
that's what i was going to say carlos
actually
the twin sisters where they were
androids they were designed to to behave
like human beings when they didn't know
they were an android so they ate and
drank and i imagined pooped
and peed i don't know why i'm
concentrating on the pooping part as
much as i am but
i i don't know i just have this thing
about data or an android wipe in his own
ass i don't know why that amuses me
um it's considering that there are never
toilets on these ships the sci-fi things
they never put the toilets i got the
technical manual for star trek next
generation there's a single toilet on it
um but anyway um
so maybe that's a bit it is he's
designed as an android but he is
basically human but i just wish he would
come up and go
and then he could click his fingers and
make us all forget the last episode of
star trek season one they're very very
important lots of advantages there they
would be good the other thing i like in
picard series to trailer though
is that um they've brought back some of
the original star trek designs there's a
steamroller design and an equinox design
and those are the two ships that are
chasing
um the the picard ship which i forget
the name of um
their chase they're about to do the the
the sun maneuver sort of thing they're
trying to stop them
i'm just glad they didn't bring back
those it's almost like they
they they've watched back the last
episode and gone oh god we really
dropped a kegger there guys these ships
are hideous
um you know it's like so let's let's
actually bring back some proper star
trek episodes or they might lynch us and
i was all up for lynching um kersman at
the end of star trek season one yeah the
nova class carlos you're right that is
an over class
uh it was the equinoxes and over classes
and i think
um
so i mean
do you think they're actually listening
do you think this might be a bit better
i think so i mean it's i mean you know
the
sometimes i think you know bringing back
gynan is kind of like what df-9 did with
wharf
you know
perking it up you know trying to
bring back some of the former glory and
the same thing with q i mean one of the
best villains in tng was
q
you know yeah
i mean
i never thought
huh i never thought him as a villain i
don't i know q doesn't think of himself
as a villain
he's just he's a trickster
he's um you know he's a he's a cheeky
little chappie
um
i have a theory though about that the
queue might not be as good but i'm not
saying a word because i'm not ruining
another one videos that i haven't put up
yet
um damn it um but there is going to be
another video about the cube coming up
please watch it my star trek videos
never do very well and
please watch them anyway um
well speaking about androids and poop
you may know more about this topic than
i did you probably do
you think i know about two people
well oh so is there going to be another
season of westworld
i don't know actually i think it's been
cancelled
has been canceled because i thought the
third season was really the best
um the last thing i heard was that it
was it was definitely on hiatus anyway
it was on pause um the second series
didn't do very well did it it it kind of
um
it kind of bombed i think they lost a
few
fans through that um
and i to be honest we've not had the
third season in the uk so i've not seen
it
so but the last thing i heard
it was uh on hiatus it was on break okay
i mean it
a lot of things went on break some never
came back because of covert
here's one i don't know why it came back
and this is um
oh it's the hbo show
again androids raised by wolves
i've never seen it
i can't i mean
the it started out really good
and then the last episode was just so
either transcendental
or i didn't get my lsd blots in the mail
to watch that episode for the i mean it
was just what the hell is going on
yeah and it's just okay that's got to be
the it it's done
seasons two two started this month
on hbo we haven't got that in the uk um
we haven't got a proper hbo channel over
here though it's basically if it doesn't
if sky atlantic was which is
the big satellite
right we never really had cable as such
we got virgin media which did the cable
most of ours the satellite was the big
provider sort of like a
big of sky channels so we've got sky if
it doesn't go sky atlantic
it's from a hbo point of view we don't
really get it
so um
can you get the i mean because they the
i'll watch it on the streaming app which
is hbo max i think and yeah we don't get
it don't get it we haven't got hpr max
okay so it's a it's a crazy show it
really starts out great
and then i just
man somewhere around two thirds of the
way through the season it was like wha
what and i don't know maybe other people
viewers will
have grocked it i just
and i grok a lot of [ __ ] i just could
not get through this it was just
answered question before we made it has
been renewed for season four but there's
no release date so it wasn't a bit of a
break but it's like you said there's a
lot of tv shows that have been on um
on on a break even though when kovid's
come back it's just a massive backlog of
projects
and so many things have been put on
pause
um
or or like you said just not come back
at all yeah um we're talking about the
expanse at the moment they've you know
the because that's a bit of a funny one
that the tv show is owned by the
production company
um
aeon or atom or something after they're
called alcon or something like that
um
so
they own the production they own the
rights to it but amazon basically bought
three series
um
then
they um basically i wasn't extending
what we don't want to buy anymore
so they've just said well okay well
we're not cancelling it amazon said
basically it's cancelled we're not
having another one
um but actually the production company
going well
we've still got sort of three series we
could make
so there i mean about i think apparently
amazon were thinking about doing a uh
trilogy of movies and thinking about
buying trilogy at movies and they
actually stored boarded it all out i did
a video on this couple weeks ago
storyboarded all out but i'm hearing now
um from the people i know
that that uh getting around in these
circles that maybe amazon have looked at
the numbers and thinking
it's not worth it
that the cost is too much
but technically
the production companies still own this
and still want to make the last three
series
if somebody picks it up like hbo max or
netflix even
because um
expanse was actually on netflix
originally in the uk i think it was on
the sci-fi network and
it started it's been all over yeah it
started with sci-fi
and uh then i think it was then to
netflix
then it got ported to amazon so yeah
it's it's i think i think it was only
yeah we've had it on i think it was the
first three two or three series for
netflix over here and then the last
three series have all been on amazon um
because obviously netflix canceled it um
but then there's rumors that it might
bounce back to netflix now um but i'm
gonna have to do another video on that
now because i've been told that since
did a big long video about how it might
they might get three movies now it turns
out probably not
um but one of the things they do with
these things apparently is when they
were um
they they do the storyboard it all out
and one of the exercises okay how much
will actually cost to make that
and when they sort of did the math
the amazon people went no
i think we're not writing that check
well yeah i mean
some of the rumors i've heard and these
you again probably know more than i
would
is that
amazon really spent a lot of money to
obtain the rights to lord of the rings i
think it was
billion billion
was it 250 million was it somewhere
around a million now it's a billion
dollars um and that's just for the
rights is that correct uh no they've
that's including them the production
cost of the first series
yeah so i think they got the rights very
limited rights for a quarter of a
billion dollars from the tolkien estate
and everything else is the production
yeah and so if they've spent a billion
dollars i understood yeah it was
hundreds of millions of dollars for this
first season
man how much more money do they have
i mean i mean i'm just wondering how
many other productions have gone by the
wayside because they're spending so big
on lord of the rings well i mean that
was the big thing with the expanse was
basically because jeff bezos is a fan he
actually read the books himself he's a
fan so if they if if amazon do end up
deciding yes we're going to produce
these it'll basically it won't be
because of the viewers because not
enough people watched it people watched
it love it
but nothing like enough people watch it
um
and the people that do is half a billion
dollars apparently carlos says
absolutely so um
so uh oh and he says it wasn't netflix
in the uk it was on netflix i'm
reasonably sure but i might be wrong um
because i watched it first i'm sure it
was on netflix um because we don't have
a siphon here we have a sci-fi channel
but it's actually doesn't really have
very good tv shows it's like one of
those channels that's 133 on your
channel list sort of thing on sky tv
well side flight used to be really good
and then they started uh
doing wrestling at night
oh really we don't get that yeah yeah it
was getting lots of really cheap
quite cheap sci-fi
shows
oh yeah we've got a live shot made um
but like uh there's some space on i
forget what it's called now but um it
was just very cheap and cheerful and
it's quite good sci-fi but it was like
you know
um
not you wouldn't really it's nothing
you'd write home about something um
but but yeah i mean so
if they if they do go ahead with that
it'll be because jeff bezos or somebody
else
wants to it won't be because of the
viewership of the with the expansion the
critics love the expanse i mean i think
it was season three he's got on rotten
tomatoes it's like a 100 mark and ninety
percent with the um with it with the
with the people watching something you
know
sci-fi shows never get that i i know a
lot of people that are not purposely are
not sci-fi fans that loved the
yeah
exactly because it's gritty and it's a
bit more real yeah it's got so many
layers to it um but i was watching about
today and i've never really thought
about it before but they're sort of
saying that actually the
it goes in phases the books like the
first and second books sort of go
together then you got the first book and
then the second book kind of explains
what happened in the first book and and
then the third and the fourth ones go
together and then the fifth season and
then definitely the sixth season but
they're all sort of like slightly
different genres like the second
season's more like almost like a horror
mm-hmm or a horror story sort of thing
and then and the third one's like a
haunted house story which i loved i
never thought about it until until
somebody described it like that and i
said like yeah it kind of was well then
the sixth season was like an adventure
but apparently the seven eight or nine
are like a fantasy adventure more
right so i was thinking oh okay um and
they go together
and i've never read the books um
i said i'd tell a lie i've read the
first book but i've never got around to
reading the rest but i'm like that
sounds like that would kind of work in a
maybe a movie trilogy sort of thing
which is what apparently amazon were
thinking about doing the other good
thing about the trilogy idea is between
book six and book seven is a gap of like
40 50 years i think it's 30 years but
yeah 30 years yeah yeah yeah so it's
makes it difficult but then they did
purposely introduce characters in the
sixth season
that that aren't really important in the
six book at all but they are very
important in seven eight to nine
so that's a big thing with people why
did they bother doing that and it's
basically because shit's got alcon or
something like that the production
company that actually owns the rights
um
want to make it
they're hoping to make it in one guys or
another um two or three of the actors
have come out and said that they think
fans are going to be very excited about
what happens in the next few months
they've just got to get a customer
alcon just needs to get keep saying
alcon like that's the word like that's
the company it might not be but um but
the company that owns the rights they
just need to get somebody to buy it and
a lot of people are saying hbo max
but should be i mean you know it
wouldn't be the first time that uh hbo
picked up something like that and ran
with it you know
i think they'd have to do it in a
different way though because i think
because
a couple of years a couple of the
seasons are on um
amazon a couple of them are on somewhere
else and a couple of you know what i
mean it's so split up something i think
the only way they would do it is if they
could make it but i think the easy way
to make it different
is by making a trilogy of films
or even
you know a trilogy
because there's a lot to go through if
you're going to make it into one movie
but you could make a trilogy
for one book and a trilogy and a trip
you know you could all serious length
mini series or something you know it's
like that if you need to do something to
separate it from
maybe the first six series you know to
me
expanse
something
to um to sort of separate it but i think
experience
new horizons
your ville new horizons i can't wait for
the offer uh but yeah i think they could
easily do it it's just whether they will
or not it's
well i think we'll find out in the next
few months by the science of it
um i think we'll find out that amazon
don't want to i think that's going to be
the next big story if amazon aren't
interested
but
we'll see we'll see they saved it once
before maybe they can save it again
fingers crossed but i tell it's just
it's just a uh
thing they won't want to make it because
it's not a reboot of something else
so they won't want to do it
it's just like it's like everything at
the moment's got to be
a reboot or a remake or a re you know
imagining of something else or
nobody in hollywood hollywood seems to
want to make it
here's something
this is
a little bit of star trek in here um
way back in the
previous century
there was a show called time tunnel
i remember time so you remember well my
god bless your heart so anyway yeah time
tunnel was uh you know i loved it and i
would love to see that show came back to
come back and so i got to see it again i
found it on
to me or some sort of free streaming
service i can't remember and i i was
really bothered one of the actors i
could not place him i mean the voice was
kind of the same and some of the
mannerisms were the same and then it hit
me the guy that played uh newman tony
the dr newman on time tunnel was the
same guy that played vic fontaine in
deep space nine and mine
yes can you believe it
you know i can't because you told me but
i am just like oh my god it's just yeah
time tunnel was made by the same people
that made uh land of the giants and
uh lost in space wasn't it
it was all very similar look to it yeah
yeah yeah built in technicolor
um let's see it was erwin allen yeah
irwin allen was the creator
i always thought time tunnel was um the
inspiration i should say for um quantum
leap
um
i always felt that was sort of like a
similar sort of thing which which we are
getting rebooted
um and scott cooler
is apparently definitely not going to be
in it not even the opening episode
um i'm being told so um which people are
very upset by so everyone that's another
one people are jumping up going it's
going to be woke like will you calm down
until they make it
ziggy is going to be some sort of alt
binary you know something another from i
don't know giraffe dna in a super
computer i don't know
i just wish people to calm down before
that show actually gets made don't jump
up and down i want to see about locati
that's what i want to see
okay
yeah is the a how how how how woke can
we get a this ai is binary well yes it
is because it's
exactly unless it's good
we just need to get quantum ai then what
is
it it's quantum leap so it's gotta be
right see see
yeah but um i i think it'll be a shame
actually if scott pakula doesn't appear
for at least one episode so i think it'd
be a nice way because him and um dean
stockwell were really good yeah they
really yeah stock will
and i think it would be a nice way to
sort of like tip a hat to dean stockwell
but also it could make sense that um
that the the idea plot idea was bouncing
around was that it's going to be his
daughter
that is now um works for the quantum
leap
company i don't know um but if she works
there she's trying to figure out how to
get her dad home and she figures out a
way but the only way to do it is to
basically replace him
and so he he gets it he's you know she
gets a dad home and then there's the end
of the episode it's going to be
basically him her stuck
in in a in the leap
and i thought that'd be that's a nice
way of doing that that could do that
could work
yeah
that would work i saw something about
quantum leap here on my twitter feed
this last week it was something about
um quantum leap was is was really a
spin-off of the original battlestar
galactica
i read the article and i think it's one
article is one of those you know click
bait something another just to get
because it made no sense
it's made by the same people isn't that
liz um i want to say i was going to say
hank lazario again what's his name
um
[Music]
fighting thing at the end
now he made all of those tv shows he
made a wolf in a team and
was basically just a tv going
star wars is popular
star wars right right right right uh
what's his name
yeah so then he did he did quantum leap
as well yeah he did a bunch of stuff
there's the only thing i can think of i
i can't think of a single link between
parts like constantly
huh
oh let's see um
he's the uh i see the new magnum pi ncis
y50
quantum leap
tequila and bonnetti don't know what
that is airwolf
here's one like the tales of the gold
monkey
no that one's done it was like a uh
is like a kind of
a um
south pacific
post world war ii
kind of adventure series i think it came
out before
maybe before indiana jones is very much
like that and the guy had a seaplane
some sort of grumman seaplane and he'd
fly around have adventures i do remember
that
i remember that yeah he did that too um
oh he also did black sheep squadron
i don't know if you remember that
it was um
another south pacific but during world
war ii
uh it was based on a true uh true story
the atta from a uh command uh captain in
the
army or marines a captain pappy
boyington
what a name what a name right that's a
legendary name i wish my name was papi
that's all right we're gonna
come to an end in a minute but
yeah we are sure carlos has just has
just had a um thing well i say we're
gonna come to an end until we start
talking about something else and then
the wife and banging the door going
you've said half out
um
just tell a story enough for the sex
difference right
somebody i know this isn't going to be
aimed at you now carlos but somebody
actually left a comment today on a post
i put up and it was about um
buck rogers and they said it'll be
betting ranches and i went ah well
i think why would they do that they
won't call it betty for the love of god
but anyway i i understand that the joke
um
but then they did say that it would be
it would be i've just had enough of all
the sex they keep pushing sex down their
throats and i was just like have you
seen buck rogers everybody was in
spandex and the villain was in a bikini
for most of the series yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i said like sex sells sex is always sold
and in sci-fi particularly what is if i
say you know the the second star wars
movie return of the jedi what's the most
famous scene in that movie and it's not
going to be that oh well there was uh
the thai fighter scene or that it's
going to be
princess leia in a gold bikini it's
iconic you know it's like
sex cells don't it i mean i know a lot
of modern stuff i think
i do think in sci-fi all on all tv or tv
now um they get a lot more past the
senses than they used to
tv shows had to be a lot cleverer to get
stuff past the senses
um i remember swatching so about i think
it was about the simpsons
um and they were saying how did you get
all the you know you get these quite
grown up jokes and it's because the
senses don't understand them they just
think we're a kid's cartoon so they're
not really watching so as long as we
don't specifically say the word
we can get a lot past them so then we
know but they had to be really clever
about it and a lot of old sci-fi shows
you know they're they're they're quite
sexual and they're quite dirty and
they're going up but but they were
clever about it there was something
barbarella comes to mind barbarella was
basically a softcore porn movie
um
you know um
right
exactly
i i know you're saying here soon and
they told the story but it was very
sexualized and i'd say it was a big part
of the thing so there was no reason for
that villain to be in a bikini but she
was because it was sexy you know and
that didn't drive the story on at all
she was supposed to be this powerful
like colonel or general or something but
she was gonna be heard like too serious
um there's no reason for it they still
do what i'm saying
i think a lot of the stuff that some
people get i i have i have had debates
with people about this work because some
people have really thoughtful they've
really thought it through and they're
based at the end of the day and they've
got good point
a lot of stuff is going on at the moment
is politicized and it's not
um in a good thing and and and the the
gender stuff and things i get i think
you have to be really careful about
because you're really in danger of
sounding like a bigot if you go if you
haven't thought your argument through
some people really brilliant they've
really thought they're arguing through
and i can't fault him for it
other people just go well i don't like
transgender stuff so i don't want on my
tv screens
and i'm like well
it's not really the point
but saying this about like oh
it's too sexualized i'm like that's
always been the case it's always been
sexualized have you seen early roman
greco art
there's a lot of penises
so yeah
how many renaissance paintings have you
know boobs out
yeah exactly
wheat men like boobs you can't i can't
really argue with that um
i personally love them so what you can
do
but but yeah i mean i i just thought
that was an odd argument for him to say
let's get all this sex stuff off my
screen i'm like
i think you need to watch more tv it's
been it's it's you know it's always been
away isn't it it's like
in in all of storytelling
it's always been that way um
hey i think so
yeah and just to answer your ian's
question there um
[Music]
no
okay uh the doctor who is really a bit
of a low ebb at the moment its
popularity is pretty low doctor who's
coming back so torchwood won't be and
it's not doing great at the moment
things like blake seven and anything
jerry anderson like thunderbirds is
actually already been rebooted there's a
series of thunderbirds on at the moment
um
other stuff like that they tried a few
years ago and they were very expensive
to make and they just bombed
and so they they didn't they didn't go
anywhere so but not that i'm aware of
anyway nothing nothing like that is
being rebooted
um we don't really have a vibrant
um science fiction
um making industry at the moment in the
uk other than doctor who because it's
really expensive to make and a lot of
our tv channels can't do it even though
a lot of the sci-fi shows that you love
and watch are actually filmed and made
here
and pinewood studios is one of the most
successful
studios in the country in the world
really you know we have skills and stuff
here
if you watch a marvel movie the chances
are a lot of it was filmed here in the
uk
you know and there's a lot of special
effects and stuff are done here so
on that topic um i went to dragon con in
atlanta several years ago and i met the
guy that makes a lot of the uh props for
doctor who
and you know he he's uh what's his name
it's uh he has a company about the sells
uh raw license replicas rubber rubber
toe productions or something like that
okay anyway brilliant guy brilliant guy
you know and the funniest thing the
thing i remember most about the uh the
uh conversation is he kept having to
make or repair the sonics
for
oh dr
doctor the number was it the 13th
matt
not special
matt smith he said yeah matt smith man
he could [ __ ] up a rubber ball
[Music]
who i apologize i don't know his name
i'm not a big hoovie
um but um
the guy that i think said hated the
bug-eyed monsters from like 1950s movies
and things he hated
and then so he created the daleks
um and but he he didn't really envisage
what they would look like and somebody
in the prop department probably just had
to have to create a dalek and obviously
it comes out with the exterior minutes
and he hated it
he said it was the ultimate bug-eyed
monster until he saw it on screen and
then he just he just fell in love with
it but he admit very we very very nearly
didn't get the daleks he kicked off he
hated it
wow um
and then it turned out to be one of the
most awesome stare challenged bad guys
in there in history until they started
flying
i was basically dust spin sort of bug i
think but um now doctor who is one of
those series that when matt smith was
the doctor he was my favorite i love
david tennant
so
but um since then i haven't watched it
i can't watch it we used to have the
christmas special here in the uk
i know
it's five o'clock christmas day doctor
who for about 10 years
um and now they've moved you know that
it's popularity's way because now it's
the new year's day
special
and
you know who cares good evening alan how
are you sir
hello
i should say that anybody i've forgotten
to add the description that's the link
to your channel
stormy
sorry
i'll add it later um i will also put it
on the community page guys so please go
and have a look and please go and
subscribe
i forgot it's sunday i'm busy shut up
stormy
i've been cooking sunday dinners all day
today oh my god
and and drinking alcohol
and for anybody that remembers our lives
our very very first
very first live show or a second live
show where we had with our friend of the
channel spencer
who got very drunk and then fell asleep
it's the greatest moment i wish i'm
going to clip it and put it on because i
mean obviously the channel has just
exploded since then and thank you
everyone who subscribes to my channel
you legends
um
but obviously nobody really watched that
video because it was very very early on
we were talking about the second or
third thing we ever did i need to clip
it and put it back over there because
just watch this sponsor
and just you know clip you know just
edit that port just his face just his
part of the screen he just
and obviously he decided to come dressed
as a
[Music]
we're gonna go to um
the big um star trek convention here in
the uk um in london hope i'm really
hoping mikey and spencer are gonna come
anyway in october and say we're gonna
get dressed up and if he doesn't come as
a trail
he got so sensible and he was from
brilliant arguments we were talking
about star wars and star trek which is
better and you know i think comparing
the two and things and there's some
really and then he just started like a
pissed person in the um
yeah
he was definitely channeling something
from the center of the universe man and
then a switch went off for something and
yes and then he just
and then and then
we're getting more questions coming the
flash gordon reboot is getting into a
bit of a legal qualifier
because there's a bit of a problem for
the flash gordon reboot i'm just going
to take a question
um in that
um
nobody can quite decide who owns it
so one company say they own it and this
is being made by a production company
that's owned by george clooney and they
want to make um a tv series based more
like what the original comic book was
um but the family of the guy that wrote
it says we own it you can't do it
but the character of flash gordon's like
over 100 years old
so it gets into a bit of a thing like
it's been like sherlock holmes you know
like people can make
sherlock holmes movies they don't have
to play the arthur conan doyle
estate loads of royalties because it's
sort of in the public domain
but flash gordon sits in a bit of a
thing like that right
in the original comic book he was never
actually called flash gordon in the in
the original novella sorry
so the so the family say we own the
novella which is he wasn't called flash
gordon i'm doing this for memory now so
you have to excuse me if i got this
wrong but then in the comic book they
went
we've we changed they changed the name
and this other company owned the comic
book
so you've got one company that knows the
novella and one company that owns the
comic book both saying we own flash
gordon and
it's got into a bit of a legal quagmire
and so the company both are actually um
creating a series or in early stages
development creating one creating the
movie once creating a series
and the people that own the novella the
family have basically sent george
clooney letter saying do not make that
series a cease and desist letter
and yeah it's going to get very very
messy
um but i'm more interested in who owns
the queen music because if they don't go
i have somebody go flash oh
he's a girl then it's not flash gordon
anything and also
um
brian blessed is like 90 years old
and don't get me wrong he could still
outrun me and he could still climb up
over us faster than i can if you don't
know anything about anything about brian
blessed he wants plant everest that's
why that's
that's why i said
um but
i don't want to see that man in hot
pants
which we basically got for the series um
he's a nine-year-old man
so um and and could you honestly nobody
else could play that character in a
million years any other character and
anybody could play but
i'm blessed come on he's the legend
so yeah
i think i don't think we're going to be
getting a flash gordon series anytime
soon
even
yeah that's i think that's going to be
it's
you know i think what would be a good
series is um
whenever uh on a voyager they'd go to
the holodeck and they'd have the uh
doctor what was it what was the uh the
uh the black and white
uh holodeck recreation what was it the
um
do you know it was like this
black and white with um
the holodeck itself was in black and
white and the whole thing was like buck
rogers i forget the
the villain's name voyager you mean yeah
it was yeah
yes i'm so sorry um so yeah but it was
it was very flash gordon wasn't it but
it was like the original flash gordon
series so it was like yeah with this
rocket [ __ ]
and things yeah yeah yeah yeah i can't i
think they i don't think it was i think
it was supposed to be flash gordon but
didn't they create a different like oh
is it completely different name
yes
was that yes
queen arachnia queen of the spider or
something yeah yeah that is just proton
that was it there's that captain protein
happy proton yes thank you
ian like to see a series like that you
know another thing another sci-fi series
i'd like to see is something based off
of uh red mars
oh yeah okay stanley robinson
the war series red
mars blue mars green mars
that would be i mean to me that was kind
of the level that you'd see from um the
expanse that kind of
rain of a little bit in the future not
too far-fetched you know it's not in the
year 3000 or whatever after the burn
it was just it's uh
i thought that would i mean i loved
loved that series
and i'd loved it i mean that would make
a great
episodic show it really yeah i think so
i wish they would bring in that because
i've seen them they're supposed to be
bringing back the six million dollar man
which i did a video on a couple weeks
ago as well the six billion dollar man i
wish they would come back as a series
they tried to bring back the six billion
million dollar woman basically and there
was actually a zoe something as a
british actress and it was okay
but it got canceled after like by six
episodes
but it was all right i think the problem
was it was an act they picked an actress
nobody knew
so in britain we were like oh zoey's on
a tv show in america in america they
went who the hell is this chick and
nobody cares
um but um i just i wish they'd make
actual tv series because i think
nowadays our relationship with
technology is so um
confusing we're slowly becoming the borg
and um
it's happening and actually i think a
series like the the six million dollar
man done like the original
series that was it became
a donald b pete belisario tv show
eventually you know you know halfway
through the thing and it lost its
grittiness but a gritty tv show um you
know unwilling
spy and all that sort of thing in our
political landscape we have today but
mainly
the relationship he has with the
technology he tried to commit suicide
initially because he couldn't
cope with what had happened to him
um you know so i think that sort of
thing would be i mean really interesting
tv show i've done right but
get a major film
oh my god timothy olyphant as uh
as the uh
oscar goldman
oh that would be good i like that would
that just not be an astonishing casting
that would be good man i like dr goldman
head of the os i i think it was um
that would be good yes you heard it here
we thought i found everything i loved
justified it was one of my favorite
shows that was really good i absolutely
loved jokes i i knew his whaler that's
his name way little justified
i'd love that show anyway right guys we
are at the hour and a half mark so we
are going to call it an evening of
course we are um because i've got work
tomorrow oh and um
i i still have a full-time job and i
still do this channel i don't generally
don't know how i do it sometimes i
sometimes put videos out and i think i
haven't put like stuff in the background
and you know like pictures and videos
and things and i was thinking i don't
have time in my life somebody moaned at
me about not not doing you could do a
bit more because do you want a video or
do you not want a video because i'm just
working on all day and i don't give a
[ __ ]
but i don't i love doing it that's
something i really love doing um but but
yeah so i promised the wife would be off
my outfit
picked up a teaching gig man and um yeah
hours are limited to [ __ ] around with uh
youtube videos i mean they just are
yeah these are like a way out in the
desert and discover something like i've
got one i've been working on forever the
lichen of mojave desert
and who wants to be you know a half hour
awaken
one day
i'll get my liking video done
i am going to america in a couple of
years me and my pal are going to hike
the um
rockies
but i i might just end up dropping in
near you somewhere mate because well i
would love you're gonna have to show me
some of these my hobie caves i would
love to go
yeah yeah you i think you'd like them
yeah and cool and and i just want to
give you a big bear hugging
oh my gosh i'm from another continent
my uh rocking amigo um
i wasn't gonna say that anyway i was
gonna go somewhere else with that
conversation then that's just lost me
i've lost my train of thought
it might be the alcohol that's done it
could be the alcohol because your glass
is empty so therefore you must refill it
i need to go and get more
thank you so much stormy and very lovely
so i know only lunch down there your
lucky sub it's nine o'clock early see
you in two weeks is that correct we are
going to be doing this every fortnight
and it's just going to be two old farts
who you all fart he said this
hello
mine's slightly more aged than his yeah
and yeah i'm all far hello
hello
and we haven't mentioned our bad knees
or our bad backs once oh i'll [ __ ]
about my back this week actually i
haven't absolutely
complained about it it won't stop
raining here and my hip is killing me
um and you know i know when the rain's
coming that's when i realized i'm old
when i actually went i think it's going
to rain and somebody went why because
because my hip hurts
how old are you
um but uh and i meant it i know i said
it with absolutely no humor or irony
but um you know the first time you bend
over and then you stand up and go you
made that noise and you realize it was
you
oh man the other night i turned over in
bed in my you know it twisted a little
bit and my spine sounded like bubble
wrap cracking from like
sir right on down
that's good it felt glorious but it was
felt weird too
we're out my insurance policies are very
low and which has never been that so
there are advantages for being old um
i'm wise
uh
and um i've actually got savings now
which i've never had in my life
we i need to actually my channel is
actually doing really nicely at the
moment but i need to earn enough money
to go down to four days a week at work
so then i can do more videos so at any
point you guys just want to give me
money i'm okay with it
i don't like begging
but
four days a week
can you can you set up a patreon do you
have a patreon i could do but i i don't
i don't i'd rather youtube paid me twice
with adverts
yeah but you can join the channel and
give me money and four lovely people
have done which i i think they're great
thank you so much for that
honestly though it seems it feels a bit
silly i do this as a hobby
you know i do it because i love doing it
so
people actually give me their money
feels a bit like well you know no
youtube give me their money
then you know they can advertise on my
channel and i'm fine with that and i can
earn my pennies from that and you know
it's like a nice little bit of money
every month not a lot but
um
but i'd have to earn quite a lot to
actually go down four days a week and
the wife would make me like
you know she wouldn't be like okay
you've earned five japan this month does
that mean you can't buy it for this week
the american tax man takes 30
you're welcome american i don't want to
fund
your military complex
yeah 30 of my pennies that makes a
difference well we got to buy all this
tea to throw back into the harbor from
some place
oh man i'm going to leave you with this
we just swapped tax revenues i mean we
went from the british system to the
american system and it's just
nothing changed yeah the flag didn't do
this
you just you just give your money to a
president instead of jack queen that's
what would change
um i could leave you with this though
right because i had a video and i in a
minute in the uk um a tv series it's
just a tv series so now like star trek
tv series and then there are seven
seasons right we don't really say that
in this country we just call them more
serious
a serious is anything that's a serious
like one two three four five it's a
series
we that's what we say so i've said in a
few videos it's a series
i had a comment
bloody british
accent for some reason he accused he
blamed my accent which i didn't
understand but it says blue british
accent um it's a series a season is the
22 episodes a series is the whole damn
thing you're actually called me several
names
so i just put aluminium
argument over because you can't even say
the language you invented and then call
me a bunch of names
absolutely i got a better response i got
a better response
you just next time say oh we use the
metric system
[Laughter]
i will do that next time
it was the bit that he's you know if
he's i'm gonna go to somebody for being
pedantic you know saying no i think it's
a bit you know this here is a serious
does it really matter but it's gonna be
don't
begin the argument by going in you and
your stupid accent what's my accent
gotta do with me using the wrong word
let's go
like so i wanted to tear it apart but i
thought now i can't be honest
but um i do get some crazy
yeah and i don't even know why the
americans dropped the eye the extra eye
out of aluminium
yeah
there's a there's a song by biffy cairo
right that goes um
apron answered alamini i'm going to sing
there sorry i pronounced aluminium
because there's a night next to the unm
now write it down slowly
and saying i'm back and then but then it
goes on about sleeping with your cousin
it goes wildly left well that's
memorable right
yeah it's it's on about spelling and
then just goes into uh sleep with your
sister it's like whoa right okay doctors
people wait everything has to go back to
shakespeare with you people
yeah
it's it's our one success leave us alone
okay fine um hey
you just be grateful we i let your
company or your country be born well
hello we invented you so um
50 of my views come from america i love
america
new york is the greatest city on earth
please don't unsubscribe
well i mean you just you just have you
know let's be correct you had um a hand
in it for the 13 colonies and then there
was the louisiana purchase so which and
then there was some french and then
there was you know of course the spanish
and let's not forget the big chunk of
mexico we got with the americans uh
mexican war now we took about more than
what 40 percent of their country and
called them 10 new states including
texas
and of course then there was the czar of
russia when we just stole alaska and
then we just went to hawaii and stole
that from hawaii so yeah you you were
just the first a long list
of empires
that we
screwed
and then became an empire all on your
own that's right
america america thank you guys for sure
right until two weeks if i still have a
channel because we've sworn a lot on
this video as well on youtube and we
have some scene with those that's the
most important thing
um
like spring summer housing
i will see you in two weeks guys all
right two weeks peace y'all be good
thanks for everyone dispute speak to you
later bye guys